sommer sonne und sehnsucht nach meer
hier in der küste von istrien erwartet
man in diesem jahr eine rekordsaison was
manche touristen nicht ahnen ihr
ferienparadies ist auch ein zufluchtsort
für kriegsflüchtlinge aus der ukraine
olina cormier cover flow vor den bomben
in der süd ukraine während ihr mann an
der front schützengräben aushebt deckt
sie für die urlauber den mittagstisch
die gäste sind manche merken dass ich
aus der ukraine kommen sie verstehen
unsere situation und manche helfen dann
sogar wenn ich mal was vergessen habe
beim service
seit einem monat arbeitet sie jetzt hier
ein bisschen kroatisch hat die 38
jährige lehrerin für tourismus und sport
schnell gelernt
für uns aus der ukraine ist es wichtig
dass wir arbeiten und geld verdienen
können und dass wir an einem sicheren
ort sind
mein mann ist immer noch in der ukraine
er muss dort für unser land kämpfen
als elena am nachmittag pause hat zeigt
sie uns ihre wohnung sie verdient rund
800 euro im monat dazu gibt es
kostenfrei unterkunft und verpflegung
ein durchschnittlicher lohn ihr 15
jähriger sohn jenny ist zum glück mit
ihr in sicherheit doch in gedanken ist
immer in der heimat jeden tag ruft sie
zu hause an die beste freundin erreicht
sie heute bei der arbeit sie nett
schutzwesten für die ukrainische armee
jeden morgen wache ich auf wo für meine
familie und meine freunde an und frage
wie war die nacht denn die ist am
gefährlichsten dann lese ich die
nachrichten
als wir hier angekommen sind gab es ein
geschenk für uns eine große kiste mit
essen und der direktor sagte ihr wart
lange unterwegs jetzt müsst ihr erstmal
essen und schlafen
das so lena so gut aufgenommen wird ist
kein zufall
im kroatischen tourismus fehlen rund
35.000 fachkräfte viele kroaten sind
abgewandert nach deutschland zum
beispiel denn dort wird besser bezahlt
andere haben wegen corona den job
gewechselt
das betrifft auch andere branchen dass
zehn prozent der kroaten in den
vergangenen zehn jahren ausgewandert
sind ist für kroatien eine nationale
katastrophe
in zagreb treffen vier petric der eine
arbeitsvermittlung führt auch ihn
bedrückt die abwanderung
wenn die jungen leute gehen die etwas
verändern wollen gibt es keine
entwicklung das sind doch die die
anpacken ohne die versinken wir immer
tiefer
peter lovric versucht den aderlass
auszugleichen dabei helfen bewerberinnen
aus der ukraine
rund 20.000 flüchtlinge kamen bisher
nach kroatien
für ukraine ist es sehr leicht sich in
kroatien zurechtzufinden unsere sprachen
ähneln sich sehr was der verständigung
untereinander hilft anfangs ging es um
hilfsjobs in der landwirtschaft im bau
und im tourismus
mittlerweile arbeiten einige auch in der
medizin und in der software industrie
die personal not in der kroatischen
medizin ist jetzt die chance für
katerina neumannova 29 jahre alt
fachärztin für dermatologie
sie stammt aus den gebeutelten vororten
von kiew als die bomben fielen holten
freunde sie nach zagreb
die mentalität hier ist ähnlich und
außerdem hat kroatien vor 30 jahren auch
krieg erlebt sie verstehen uns irgendwie
und helfen uns sehr da understand
ich habe jetzt einen kroatischen ausweis
eine krankenversicherung eine
arbeitserlaubnis und mein sohn kann in
den kindergarten
was ihr noch fehlt die anerkennung ihres
medizinischen abschlusses
sie hat viele erfahrungen kliniken
dieser ukraine sind gut manche länder
haben ärzten aus der ukraine sofort
erlaubt zu praktizieren kroatien gehört
unglücklicherweise nicht dazu die
bürokratie muss unbedingt schneller
werden
ob katharina dauerhaft bleiben will oder
zurück in die ukraine weiß sie noch
nicht
wir haben keine pläne
denn manchmal hat man das gefühl dass es
kein morgen mehr gibt
im ferienresort in pula drängen sich die
gäste mittlerweile ums abendessen olena
commuter war eile durch das restaurant
als habe sie nie etwas anderes getan
die arbeit ist sehr schön vor allem auch
wegen meiner kollegen die mir viel
beibringen
ich will hier arbeiten aber wenn der
krieg zu ende ist gehe ich wieder heißt
sie sind dankbar aber sie wollen zurück
in die heimat so geht es den meisten
frauen aus der ukraine
solange dort noch krieg ist profitiert
kroatien von ihnen doch das dramatische
fachkräfteproblem können die ukraine
hier auf dauer nicht lösen
[Musik]